la suite de l'épisode de vergload des
dernières heures il y a plus de 1000
employés d'Hydro-Québec qui sait faire à
réparer les brises sur le réseau
électrique la société d'État espère
pouvoir rétablir le courant pour 60 à
80% de ses abonnés privés d'électricité
d'ici vendredi soir avec nous Régis
Tellier les vice-présidents opérations
et maintenant chez Hydro-Québec bonsoir
Monsieur Tellier et merci d'être là
votre horaire et probablement très
chargé en ce moment
oui bonsoir
comment ça se déroule vos opérations en
ce moment
les équipes sont continuées on a déjà
rétabli plus de 275 000 clients mais on
continue ils font des journées de 16
heures des grosses journées sont très
encore mobilisés un peu partout là dans
les régions touchées le pas être capable
de contribuer à l'objectif qu'on sert de
rester rapprocher près de 350 000
clients établis pour ce soir à quel type
de dégâts à faire le surtout
c'est principalement des branches des
arbres de par le poids du verglas qui
est tombé soit que pris contact avec nos
cœurs ou nos infrastructures mais
également c'est aujourd'hui la
complexité le site d'avoir accès à notre
à nos installations parce que des fois
bon il peut avoir une voiture si on est
dans un milieu très
urbain il y a beaucoup de densité
beaucoup d'arbres beaucoup de dégâts là
sur sur les sols il faut être capable de
se dégager d'intervenir rapidement là ça
a été ça le gros défi parce que quand on
garde c'est des fois on a certaines pas
avec la force des vins c'est des
protocassés des équipements au sol là on
en a eu mais de moindre mesure que ce
qu'on est habitué de voir que là on voit
que ça souvent ça peut aller plus rapide
mais c'est vraiment la complicité la
logistique d'avoir accès rapidement avec
une autre défi de pendant cette
journée-là on a beaucoup parlé des
clients privés qu'en est-il des
entreprises est-ce qu'il y a beaucoup
d'entreprises qui sont aussi touchées
par cette panne est-ce qu'on a des
données là-dessus
oui parce que tu es nous c'est sûr que
dans nos ordres de priorisation quand
c'est des certains
installations névragés pour la société
je parle d'hôpitaux mais pour avoir des
usines de traitement c'est des choses
comme ça qui va être priorisé mais pour
le reste ça peut être le même sur le
même circuit sur le même réseau moi sur
le même tronçon de ligne mais il pourra
avoir des de la clientèle résidentielle
comme qui paroi de la clientèle
commerciale mais quand que le circuit
touche il touche les deux fait que nous
on dès qu'on rétablit on fait pas
nécessairement de saignement le
spécifique quand on veut rétablir plus
client possible ça inclus les commerces
à inclut les entreprises et leur
résidentiel également
bon c'est ramène toujours la même
question est-ce que notre réseau
électrique est assez fiable est-ce qu'il
est Monsieur Tellier
oui parce que notre réseau nous dans
notre mission de s'assurer d'un service
électrique fiable c'est vraiment notre
focus de travail tous les jours mais on
le voit le caca des animaux climatique
comme celui lieu celui-là celui du temps
des fêtes au mois de mai l'an passé que
un dérées
beaucoup beaucoup à nos équipes au
terrain c'est là qui nous demande un peu
pour des déposer en novembre notre plan
d'adaptation changement climatique ou
c'est quand même la conception de nos
réseaux de distribution on vient
intervenir pour être capable d'intégrer
par exemple des diamètres plus gros au
niveau de nos poteaux on va mettre des
aubaines et le fameux fil de métal avoir
plus de résistance à certains endroits
plus dévalgiques on va tester également
des types de composantes là on parle
souvent du des composites le des poteaux
à composite pour être capable de donner
une certaine robustesse à certains
endroits donc on a vraiment identifié là
des actions qui est en œuvre en ce
moment puis on contrôle beaucoup la
végétation on a doublés investissements
soit aussi parce que beaucoup de temps
qui est associé à la végétation pour
avoir un meilleur contrôle à ce
niveau-là malgré tout l'idée de
l'enfouissement refait encore une fois
surface votre PDG Sophie brochute disait
bah c'est 100 milliards de dollars mais
ça permettrait quand même d'éviter des
épisodes qui pourraient se répéter
souvent ou de plus en plus souvent avec
les changements climatiques ce serait
rentable ou pas du tout
ça sera pas rentable on en fait de
l'enfouissement le cas c'est possible
surtout dans du nouveau développement
des choses comme ça des fois en
collaborant collaboré pardon avec le
milieu où les entrepreneurs mais somme
toute ça serait des coûts astronomiques
c'est dix fois le coup d'un réseau
aérien puis en même temps oui peut-être
ça peut des fois sortir des endroits
diminuer la fréquence des pannes mais
quand une panne faut la trouver et là tu
étais enfouie c'est pas exactement il
est où et là dès qu'il y avait trouvé
fait que les délais pourraient vraiment
s'allonger fait que nous on regarde
l'équilibre parce qu'une panne aérien on
la voit on voit la branche on est
capable de quand on la patrouille de la
trouver et quand gad El Sol on peut
avoir des kilomètres en deux points puis
on n'est pas capable de savoir les hauts
exactement et ça ça rend les choses un
petit peu plus complexes et que nous on
cherche vraiment cette équipe là cet
équilibre on a 110000 km de lignes de
distribution
de coûts ça serait des coûts assez farés
qu'il y aurait un impact assurément sur
la facturation le tarif électrique au
Québec là d'autant plus qu'on doit
comparer le coût bénéfice là quand on
parle de 100 milliards la facture serait
extrêmement salée comparativement à des
épisodes de de d'événements climatiques
extrêmes disons-le qui coûte cher oui
mais on n'est pas dans le même ordre là
on parle de quelques millions parfois
des dizaines de millions de dollars dans
le cas précis est-ce que vous avez une
idée ou une échelle pour les coups que
ça pourrait représenter pour la société
d'État
pour pouvoir se prononcer là bon moi je
suis déjà ça va être des envergure de
fait plus de 10 millions c'est vraiment
quand je vois 1000 employés étaient plus
de 1000 employés au terrain avec ça on
voit toutes nos inventeurs qu'est-ce qui
se consomme en terme de corps en terme
de d'équipement mais il y a quand même
trop tôt là pour ça prononcer avec la
durée là on pense un peu durer deux
trois jours ça pourrait se rendre à
certains endroits jusqu'à dimanche mais
c'est la durée va beaucoup nous donner
une meilleure lecture le plus qu'on va
avancer sur les coups de cette panne
mais pour donner un ordre de grandeur
pendant le temps des feuilles ça a coûté
plus de 60 millions là comme type de
travaux qui étaient qui étaient que ça a
coûté mais c'est peut-être important de
mentionner c'est pas nécessairement au
frais de du client qui paye sa facture
là c'est hydrole qui prend dans minds
ses dépenses ce type de couleur
excellent rappel monsieur Tellier merci
infiniment pour les précisions
bonne soirée et puis merci beaucoup aux
clients pour la patience puis la sortie
de sécurité c'est le plus important le
fait que vous voyez les philosophes le
désert s'il vous plaît restez à distance
laissez-les dans nos jeux intervenir ils
travaillent fort pour eux qui arrivent
pas
merci beaucoup
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI